der Teilchenbeschleuniger am CERN geht
in die nächste Runde und was da jetzt
geplant ist ist einfach nur
beeindruckend man möchte Antimaterie
erzeugen und transportieren
Antimaterie kennen wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch aus Romanen oder Filmen
aber was genau ist Antimaterie überhaupt
ist es wirklich das teuerste Material
des Universums und ist Antimaterie
eigentlich gar nicht so selten wie alle
immer denken all das erfahrt ihr jetzt
in diesem Video
[Musik]
wir schreiben das Jahr 1928 einstein hat
bereits die spezielle
Relativitätstheorie veröffentlicht
neuerdings gibt es diese seltsame
Quantenmechanik von der alle reden und
mit ihr die Schrödinger-Gleichung mit
der Relativitätstheorie wurde die
vierdimensionale Raumzeit eingeführt es
gibt also drei Raumkoordinaten und als
vierte Dimension die Zeit eine vierte
Dimension kann man sich zum Beispiel so
vorstellen in einem dreidimensionalen
Raum zum Beispiel diesem hier gerade
kann ich jedem Punkt im Raum einen
zusätzlichen messbaren wert wie
beispielsweise die Temperatur zu ordnen
das heißt dieser Punkt hier hat vier
Werte die in beschreiben xy und z und
einen Temperaturwert gerade 22 Grad in
die Relativitätstheorie übertragen ist
dieser extra Wert die Zeit also werden
Raum und Zeit quasi ebenbürtig behandelt
alles klar soweit okay
schauen uns jetzt mal die
Schrödinger-Gleichung an auf der einen
Seite der Gleichung ist eine einfache
zeitableitung und auf der anderen Seite
eine doppelte ortsableitung die
Ableitung einer physikalischen Größe
beschreibt die Änderung dieser Variable
also in unserem Fall die Änderungen in
Bezug auf Ort oder auf die Zeit und was
man hier schnell sieht Zeit und Raum
werden nicht gleich behandelt und einer
stört er sich besonders daran der
Mathematiker Paul direkt also versuchte
er eine Lösung zu finden die die beiden
Gleichungen irgendwie miteinander
vereinbart auf die genaue mathematische
Herleitung werden wir jetzt an dieser
Stelle nicht eingehen aber falls Sie an
den ausführlichen Berechnungen
interessiert seid findet ihr wie immer
in den Quellen genauere Infos dazu aus
diesen Überlegungen folgte dann etwas
sehr ungewöhnliches für jedes Teilchen
muss es theoretisch ein entsprechendes
anti-teilchen geben dieses hat eins zu
eins die gleichen Eigenschaften wie
beispielsweise Masse Spin und ISO Spin
nur in den diesen Quantenzahlen
unterscheiden sie sich das sind zum
Beispiel die elektrische Ladung oder
auch die Farbladung und baryonenzahl
also müsste es theoretisch für einen
Elektron auch ein anti-elektron geben
oder uns tatsächlich nur vier Jahre nach
direkt Vorhersage konnte so ein
anti-elektron tatsächlich gemessen
werden und wir nennen es heute Positron
positrone kommen nämlich öfters mal auf
unserer Erde vor und sind nicht wirklich
etwas Ungewöhnliches zum Beispiel
entstehen sie bei Gewittern durch
kosmische Strahlung und bei natürlichem
radioaktiven Zerfall durch die
verschiedenen Quantenzahlen von Materie
und Antimaterie folgt dass beim
Aufeinandertreffen die beiden in
Photonen also reine Strahlungsenergie
umgewandelt werden genau das wird durch
Einsteins berühmtes e = mc² beschrieben
also Masse gleich Energie
das geht aber auch genauso in die andere
Richtung aus purer Energie kann auch ein
Materie antimateriepaar entstehen das
nennt sich dann in der Wissenschaft paar
Bildung okay im Grunde genommen würde
sich also eine Antimaterie Galaxie
genauso verhalten wie unsere Galaxie da
die wenigen Unterschiede zwischen
Materie und Antimaterie das Verhalten ja
nicht wirklich verändern solange wir
also ein in sich abgeschlossenes System
mit Antimaterie haben kann dieses ein
ganz entspanntes Leben im Universum
führen vielleicht gibt es da draußen ja
einen antiseedric der jetzt gerade ein
anti-doktor Watson Video dreht den werde
ich nur hoffentlich niemals treffen denn
problematisch wird es bei so ein System
auf normale Materie trifft dann nämlich
kommt es zur Auslöschung so ein Anti
Cedric wäre schon ziemlich spannend aber
um genau zu wissen was es alles gibt
oder auch nicht gibt muss einfach noch
viel mehr geforscht werden und dazu
brauchen wir noch mehr junge
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
die sich mit Antimaterie und vielen
anderen spannenden Fragen der
Wissenschaft beschäftigen wenn du dir
das vorstellen kannst oder schon immer
großes Interesse an einem MINT-Fach
hattest dann habe ich jetzt eine super
Möglichkeit für dich der Sponsor dieses
Videos hier ist nämlich plus Mint das
ist eine Talentförderung für junge
mint-begeisterte die euch und eure
Fähigkeiten in einem von sechs
Internaten in Deutschland fördern wollen
seit dem 1 oktober läuft die
Bewerbungsphase für das nächste Jahr und
wenn ihr es dadurch schafft dann habt
ihr die Möglichkeit mit vielen
Gleichgesinnten noch tiefer in die
Fächer Mathematik Informatik Bio Chemie
Physik und Technik einzusteigen an den
Internaten habt ihr einen geregelten
Schulalltag mit Fokus auf euer
Spezialgebiet im MINT-Bereich ihr könnt
quasi den ganzen Tag forschen und euch
mit Wissenschaft auseinandersetzen und
habt abends dann auch noch die
Möglichkeit mit Freunden Sport zu
treiben oder andere AGs wie Robotik zu
machen
die Förderung ist für Schülerinnen und
Schüler ab der 9 Klasse und aufwärts die
sich durch besondere Leistungen in einem
MINT-Fach hervorgetan haben falls das
auf euch oder jemanden den erkennt
zutrifft dann schickt ihr noch einfach
in dieses Video hier oder schaut über
den ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung auf plus mint.de
vorbei da findet ihr alle Infos und ich
drücke euch die Daumen und dann geht's
jetzt zurück zu dem was wir aktuell
schon über Antimaterie wissen aber gibt
es denn irgendwo größere Mengen
Antimaterie in unserem Universum
positrone entstehen wie gesagt öfter mal
in der Natur und löschen sich dann mit
ihrem Partner dem Elektronen aus
Antiprotonen findet man hauptsächlich in
kosmischer Strahlung also eher im
Weltall wo es generell nicht so viel
Materie zum animieren gibt und ja
Annihilation ist übrigens tatsächlich
ein echtes Wort in der Wissenschaft
darunter versteht man die gegenseitige
Auslöschung von Materie und Antimaterie
antiatome oder sogar antimoleküle haben
auf der aus Materie gemachten Erde also
eine nicht so entspannte Zeit für die
Verformung eines antiatoms müssen sich
Antiprotonen und antie Neutronen finden
und den Kern bilden ebenso braucht es
dann noch positrone die sich um den Kern
herum arrangieren und das funktioniert
nur wenn keines der anti-teilchen jemals
mit normaler Materie in Kontakt kommt
aber die ist nun ja überall es ist also
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass sowas auf
natürliche Art und Weise hier auf der
Erde passiert die künstliche Herstellung
von Antimaterie wiederum hat die
Menschheit schon lange hinbekommen die
ersten Antiprotonen wurden bereits 1955
in einem Teilchenbeschleuniger des
berkly Labs künstlich erzeugt und das
erste anti-wasserstoffatom wurde 1996
künstlich erschaffen jedoch treten bei
den Experimenten mit Antimaterie immer
noch Probleme auf aber dazu später mehr
wir treffen also sehr selten mal in
unserem Alltag auf Antimaterie doch
eigentlich müsste das ganz anders sein
aus purer Energie lässt sich wie gesagt
ein Material performen
nämlich beim Urknall sollte es ja
Achtung Untertreibung relativ viel
Energie gegeben haben der perfekte Ort
also für die Geburt solcher Pärchen oder
das Verhältnis von Materie zu
Antimaterie hätte nach dem Urknall genau
eins zu eins sein müssen und danach
hätten sie sich einfach wieder
gegenseitig ausgelöscht heute dürfte
hier eigentlich nichts außer Strahlung
existieren wie wir aber ganz
offensichtlich bemerken war das
anscheinend nicht so denn wir und alles
um uns herum existieren ja eine Option
wäre dass ich die ganze Antimaterie
einfach irgendwo anders im Universum
befindet und es da draußen ganze
Galaxien aus Antimaterie gibt ein
Anzeichen dafür wären Auslöschungen von
Antimaterie und Materie an den
übergangsregionen die ausgesandten
Photonen dieser Auslöschungen müssen wir
dann eigentlich hier beobachten können
jedoch hat man noch nichts beobachtet
was diese Theorie untermauern würde also
kann man darunter noch keinen
Schlussstrich ziehen einen antisedric
gibt es da draußen also vermutlich nicht
schade die gängige Überlegung ist jedoch
eine andere ein winziges Ungleichgewicht
etwa ein Materie teilt den Überschuss
auf eine Milliarde Teilchen an die
Teilchenpaare sorgte laut Theorie dafür
dass wir überhaupt existieren können das
Ungleichgewicht zwischen Materie und
Antimaterie ist also eine der großen
ungelösten Fragen in der Physik und
davon gibt es so einige falls sie mal
ein Video darüber machen sollen schreibt
uns das gerne in die Kommentare eine
Erklärung für das Ungleichgewicht wäre
das anti-teilchen eben nicht ganz exakte
Spiegelbilder von normalen Teilchen sind
sondern beispielsweise anders zerfallen
um das zu klären muss man den
Eigenschaften der Antimaterie auf den
Grund gehen und wo geht sowas besser als
am CERN der large headron Collider ist
diesen juli mit höheren Energien als je
zuvor gestartet man schießt hier in
einem großen Beschleuniger ganz kleine
Teilchen aufeinander um neuartige
Teilchen zu erzeugen unter anderem auch
anti-teilchen die neu entstandenen
anti-teilchen bewegen sich ziemlich
schnell und wir müssen erstmal
abgebremst werden um in Experimenten
untersucht werden zu können dafür
verwendet man unter anderem starke
elektrische Felder und anschließend eine
Kühlung auf fast 0 Kelvin um die
Teilchen zum absoluten Stillstand zu
bekommen in überschlagsrechnungen geht
man davon aus dass die Produktion von
einem Gramm Antimaterie ungefähr
62,5 Billionen Euro kosten würde was Sie
theoretisch zu der teuersten bekannten
Substanz machen würde in der Praxis
wurde natürlich noch nie ein ganzes
Gramm Antimaterie auf einmal erzeugt
2011 konnte das CERN bereits
antimaterieatome über 16 Minuten lang
einfangen und 2017 hat die Lagerung von
Antiprotonen alle bisherigen Ergebnisse
völlig in den Schatten gestellt ganze
400 5 Tage lang konnte man sie aufrecht
erhalten bei den Messungen die man
danach durchführen wollte gab es aber
leider ein Problem nachdem die
Antiprotonen erzeugt und abgekühlt
wurden störte die magnetische Umgebung
des Teilchen entschleunigers die
Experimente man müsste also Antiprotonen
am besten in eine störungsfreie Umgebung
bringen um die Experimente optimal
durchführen zu können jedoch ist der
Transport von Antimaterie eine der
größten Herausforderungen in der
Forschung und das ist auch der Grund
warum so viele Forschungsfragen der
Antimaterie noch nicht mal ansatzweise
in Angriff genommen werden konnten zwei
Projekte wollen den Transport von
Antimaterie am CERN ermöglichen bei Puma
besteht der Aufbau aus einem
supraleitenden Magneten mit der
hunderttausendfachen Stärke des
Erdmagnetfeldes dieser Magnet der eine
ganze Tonne wiegt kühlt eine
Vakuumkammer auf vier Kelvin eine
Milliarde Antiprotonen sollen so zu
einem anderen Labor auf dem CERN Gelände
transportiert werden dort sollen sie
dann mit radioaktiven Stoffen reagieren
dadurch erhofft man sich neue
Informationen über Quantenphänomene
herauszufinden und das Innere von
Neutronensternen besser zu verstehen
das zweite Projekt heißt Base step
hierbei werden elektrische und
magnetische Felder genutzt um
Antiprotonen im Vakuum schweben zu
lassen das muss gemacht werden um zu
verhindern dass die Antimaterie irgendwo
auf Materie trifft da sie ja sonst
annihiliert und man dann mit der ganzen
Prozedur von vorne beginnen muss die
Vermarktung aller antimaterie2go wird
jedoch vermutlich nicht funktionieren
wenn wir uns mal diese Maße hier
anschauen immerhin ist jedoch der Plan
dass das Ganze in einen Lieferwagen
passen sollte wenn die ersten
Lieferungen einwandfrei funktionieren
möchte man Antimaterie auch über größere
Distanzen transportieren die ersten
Experimente sind noch dieses Jahr
vorgesehen dadurch könnten sich ganz
neue Forschungsfelder in der
Experimentalphysik ergeben
beispielsweise möchte man erforschen wie
Antimaterie mit Licht interagiert und
welche Wirkung die Gravitation auf sie
hat
Antimaterie sollte theoretisch genauso
aussehen wie Materie leider hat man noch
nicht so große Mengen herstellen können
als dass man das mit eigenen Augen
beurteil könnte man sucht nach den
kleinsten Unterschieden da diese
Hinweise liefern warum wir überhaupt
existieren können warum alles überhaupt
existieren kann
eine neue Theorie geht davon aus dass
Teilchen wie das charmison häufiger von
Antimaterie in Materie übergehen als von
Materie in Antimaterie das experimentell
zu beweisen könnte ein wichtiger Hinweis
sein eines der größten Rätsel der
Wissenschaft zu lösen
[Musik]
okay ich weiß das war ganz schön viel
und ziemlich kompliziert deswegen fassen
wir das jetzt noch mal in einfachen
Worten zusammen also Antimaterie ist an
sich erstmal nichts Ungewöhnliches und
unterscheidet sich kaum von normaler
Materie sie hält sich soweit bekannt wie
Materie an die allgemeinen
physikalischen Gesetze überraschend ist
aber dass so wenig davon in unserem
Universum bisher gemessen werden konnte
ergo wissen wir noch nicht sicher wie
sie aussieht wie sie auf Schwerkraft
reagiert und wie sie zerfällt jedoch
können wir immer bessere Messinstrumente
bauen und das ist wirklich wesentlich
denn durch die Erforschung von
Antimaterie erhofft man sich viele neue
Anwendungsmöglichkeiten wie
beispielsweise in der Biologie der
Materialwissenschaft und der Medizin
dort in der Medizin nutzt man übrigens
schon die Eigenschaften von Antimaterie
heute in der Positronen
emissionstomographie um unter anderem
Tumorgewebe zu untersuchen
danke fürs zuschauen wie immer bleibt
neugierig und bis zum nächsten Mal euer
Cedric oder bin ich der anti-fabrik